Come, travel back in time with me...
...as we explore the brief history of Halloween.
Today, children still go trick-or-treating,...
...a descendant of souling and many other customs that came to us...
...all the way back to the ancient Celts.
Today, we carve pumpkins,...
...put out symbols of witches, ghosts, black cats, and fortune-tellers.
We tell scary ghost stories, watch scary horror movies,...
...and dress up in all kinds of costumes,...
...not just scary ones or animal ones.
Because of safety issues, as well as some conservative religious beliefs,...
...some communities, churches, and civic organizations...
...have been offering alternatives to trick-or-treating...
...or even Halloween itself,...
...from simple fall celebrations...
...to costume parties replete with food and candy.
Over the past ten years,...
...Halloween has gone from a children's night of free candy and games,...
...spooks and scares...
....to one of the most profitable days of the year for costumers...
...and sellers of costume makeup,...
...as adults, young and old, have become enamored with this special day.